hello hi how do we start
welcome like this to the show ray thank
you we are bringing ray as a special
guest today thank you to watch something
that we've previously made and react to
it Adam what are we watching today which
eats coffee coffee wow you're very
confident in that answer somehow like
that excel a lot it's the episode I get
asked about the most uh-huh Oh coffee
expensive coffee oh yeah why is it
really worth it
where'd Japan Adam Andrew and I are
taking on Tokyo answers today we're
doing coffee you brought our good friend
tasty producer bodyguard translator see
he gray was a bad color choice you can
see the lung outline we choose the worst
times it oh yeah we went during summer
time twice oh my gosh
can we talk about this train ride sure
it's really quiet on the Japanese
friends yeah is so well I really
shouldn't be filming or talking yeah
that loud but we did it with our first
time we didn't we we know nothing
yeah what's really fun going to visit
the factory like coffee roaster cuz it's
like located a different place and like
it's bankfull you know like Tokyo it's
kinda small and everything it's kind of
small well I mean like Dance Dance OH
dance Jojo is tight yeah but this place
was kinda big Spacey episodes about
drinks are really hard because it came a
lack visual interest especially
something like coffee um and so I was
really glad that we got to go visit an
actual roaster and see all this stuff
get made
this was one of the coolest places oh
that's $1 100 yet coloring that Adam
made that okay shout out to Adam can you
believe like post like before a knee
joint you guys are the only crews
basically you film you do oh do you film
and people maybe think it's like a
larger-scale thing but basically we ran
like five people yeah my haircut is way
too new remember we have to do a big
travel trip I'm like yeah chop it off
also cuz it was gonna be so hot there I
was like cut it short hey there old
friend the first coffee shop in Tokyo
guess what year he was mounted 1887 wait
you did not see my back Vidya no but I
made an educated guess dad was amazing
what year is it
1888 and presto himself I think I think
we had maybe like heard something in an
interview
oh that I was able to Ballpark it like
that
I like music their music totally spire
in this episode yes
okay so reporters will go up Cynthia do
you wanna do almost we all need to come
on it's never cool lieutenant so you're
saying earlier how you often get asked
about the last location yeah I feel like
this middle coffee was actually the more
crazy tasting thing for me I have never
tasted a coffee like that before
it was unbelievably fruity mm-hmm it
tasted like fruit cereal yeah I feel
like let's let's keep watching
yeah it's crazy how smooth this coffee
is it's almost like a
do you taste blueberries yes scooby-doo
there is this blueberry that pulls off a
rubber mask and it's like oh my god can
you pause like I don't your kind of
watch this way right I would stand by
like off the camera yeah and I was
laughing so hard your how do you say Sal
Alosi
yeah and I think I left so hard I think
you look the Train bento boxes was some
of my favorite food we remember there's
this food court and like the bottom of a
bag yes go pick up your stuff at before
you got on the train unbelievable
shout out to uh eat your kimchi in Japan
send me Martina right yeah they gave us
the rekt actually for where to pick up
the bento boxes
yeah for sure that was super cool great
time by the way oh my god this is this
place so first off this place was like
out in a suburbs I was reloading relying
on my google map yeah it was like it was
throwing me don't know where yeah this
place I found that and I was like really
excited I was gonna be great and he was
asking so like when we arrived and he
was like oh do you wanna see the barrel
and he took me to his like little
kitchen there open the refrigerator
there was like tiny balls I was like
what am I done to you go all the way to
get motivated by this one cup of coffee
and we get there honestly I see a lot of
myself in this guy
please explain he opened a cafe just in
a residential place kind of in the
middle of nowhere but I imagine it's
just a place that he really likes he
named it after his favorite motorcycle
which is like I would do that too he has
like a extensive collection of antique
fine cups like this like this gold what
is it
Austrian or a Swiss yeah my phone is
1700s or something yeah yeah yeah I'm
saying it was a colder than Mozart older
than mine sir here's this cup of coffee
which costs $900 but then he was also
showing us this slow my extraction
method of dripping coffee so earlier
when you see the cloth filter that he
tamps down is pouring water into he
literally sat there and and dripped
water into it over the course of maybe
like 45 minutes it was more than that it
was an hour yes until a single bead
ripped out of the bottom and I remember
I was there on the tripod with the macro
lens just like any minute now Animal
Planet or the cicada like it come out of
the ground after 70 years baby
really was yeah I have a
behind-the-scenes peek Joan Murray
syndrome you are like try and so that
slow extraction method is what is in the
barrel like he did this 22 years ago to
fill that barrel which is crazy yeah it
looked like a commercial at Coffee
Camacho like single drape Wow okay
beautiful shop and it was like 11:00 we
are drinking coffee yeah it's a thick
liquid - yeah yeah it's you know it's
like syrupy and it's been sitting around
for 20-30 years so yeah yeah it's
basically like a price of Refuge Oh like
electricity right for 22 years
yeah also that slow-mo
[Music]
it's really good if like somebody took
chocolate taser and just laser rammed it
into my mouth this tastes a lot like a
dessert wine instead of making chocolate
milk it's like you used wine instead of
milk II made chocolate wine and also we
had a tissue how do you call that yeah
you would
- mm-hmm and then we got this how you
don't worry right yes we went to
restaurant 3 and we went back hotel like
4 a.m. and we start shooting next day at
like 9:00 is this what the expected
coming onto the show no fancy boys
expended money traveling the world
alignment most hard watching people like
that I was thinking like yeah I'm no
shape I want to come like whole week we
sure sure sure sure like dates no no no
like you what's fun I mean it was one of
our first international yeah real
hardcore trips so learned a lot making
that one and it's been a lot better soon
and us so hype I don't remember being
too hyper
I think it's because we drunk coffee huh
some of the best scenes you know like
backgrounds we've ever had and we don't
have any location of skull people so
like we just like oh Osaka Castle for
cake episode like it could it's you know
it could be good or like they say it's
also oh why don't you pick the cake
episode that wasn't so good oh yeah
watch the next time chocolate cake which
coffee was so tired was actually really
hard that guy was so cool great location
and possibly the best tasting cup of
coffee I've ever had the other two
places are thing today completely get
anywhere else my worth it winner was the
war over coffee from coffee uncle Mikey
my favourite worth allegation ever Wow I
said that resonate with you not to pass
[Music]
did you were the winner I knew you all
all you fancy kids are gonna say that
that's okay
roast are you always know where my heart
yeah once I read en ok it does it for
part 2 of 3 for Japan stay tuned for the
next episode which comes out next week
where we take on Ria's favorite thing
okay right
I mean do people ask you about how that
tasted like the 914 on coffee yeah I
think like most asked saying words there
grapes and my dad was like he was like
wow like he was basically called me
stupid
Oh like why did you spend that much
money for grapes somebody's gonna try it
yeah that's the show and I think that
was what I realized that like people are
like what's it worth it should I buy
that and I'm like no you should not buy
I think it's worth having the experience
that we can share that experience with
the world into our show yeah that's how
I felt they should just free watch all
of the Japan episodes which my dad is
with you one more place to take it I'll
share about this trip was I learned that
I need to learn how to
my emotions on a long international trip
where everybody's working
you're just so exhausted physically it
puts you on edge motional II I don't
know if this is interesting at all but I
feel the same way you don't realize the
toll it takes on the other aspects of
your world me yeah it's truly a
different working environment than
anything else like traveling on its own
you can we travel to vacation you feel
like you're in a whole new world you do
that for work as well it's just like I
will always have fun memories of our
Japan trance on their trip what should
we do for our third with you know what
should we do first Oh what should we do
oh yeah suck it could be good I know
some people oh all right that's been
another episode of worth it watch is
worth it
thanks for watching it will there will
be more of these yeah
[Music]